[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y con
ellos conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos más relevantes de la semana para
conversar sobre los temas que hemos
seleccionado para la semana de hoy hemos
invitado a Guillermo Antonio Ruiz él es
periodista y analista también es
director de radio ancón Guillermo
Gracias por acompañarnos cómo termina su
semana
Muchas gracias Santiago todo muy bien
gracias a Dios soleada la ciudad de
Panamá en medio del inicio del verano
y también está con nosotros Hugo Pereira
periodista y politólogo Hugo también
bienvenido Gracias por acompañarnos en
el programa ahora le pregunto a usted
cómo termina su semana allí en la ciudad
de Madrid en España Bueno pues aquí
también soleada muy bien muy buenos días
a todos buenas noches y desde luego un
placer estar con vosotros aquí pues
acompáñanos ustedes también con sus
opiniones y sus comentarios también
todas las preguntas que ustedes quieran
hacer A través de nuestras redes
sociales arroba
franz24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral una
semana en el mundo f24 todo junto todo
pegado para que ustedes dejen sus
comentarios pues vamos a comenzar
haciendo una actualización de los hechos
que tuvieron lugar a lo largo de la
semana referentes a la guerra en Ucrania
este país es el foco de la Unión Europea
a lo largo de estos días porque
justamente kiev la capital esté de esta
semana de la Cumbre de representantes de
la ue una forma de mostrar el apoyo que
tiene el bloque los 27 a la causa
ucraniana la presidenta de la comisión
europea Úrsula fonder Legend llegó a la
ciudad de gift también el jefe de la
diplomacia josephell y 15 comisarios
europeos y también estuvieron allí
presentes por ejemplo el presidente del
Consejo europeo Charles Michell tema
central pues la ruta de adhesión de
Ucrania a la Unión Europea Bruselas dice
que hay avances pero todavía falta
terreno para llegar a un proceso de
admisión o por lo menos a un estatus
significativo en este proceso de Ucrania
en su viaje hacia la Unión Europea el
presidente de lens que espera que este
año comiencen las conversaciones de
manera oficial entre tanto la ue también
anunció que financiará la reconstrucción
de Ucrania con los activos rusos que
están congelados todo esto mientras se
especula sobre una gran escalada militar
por parte de las tropas rusas en los
próximos días comienzo entonces con
Guillermo
darle pues sus impresiones sobre este
tema Europa la Unión Europea muy
decidida a dar ese apoyo a Ucrania para
un proceso de incorporación y es
significativa la presencia de todos
estos funcionarios y representantes de
la Unión Europea en quiefa a lo largo de
esta semana
Bueno también hay que tomar en cuenta
que Ucrania tiene muchos años de ser un
país señalado por corrupción a mí me
llama mucho la atención el esfuerzo que
está haciendo el esfuerzo el gobierno de
kiev en tratar de limpiar desde ahora
dentro de toda esta coyuntura la
situación de corrupción que ha venido
atravesando por qué porque evidentemente
necesitan el apoyo europeo y además esta
esta guerra puede desencadenar de
diferentes maneras hemos visto los
movimientos que se están dando en
Bielorrusia yo personalmente tuve por
por Polonia el pasado mes de noviembre
de hecho me tocó estar en en Polonia
cuando cayó un
las esquirlas de un cohete de
fabricación rusa en territorio polaco y
se la tomaron muy en serio Entonces es
una situación que es muy intensa para
Europa es muy tensa también para Ucrania
pero también hay que reconocer que
dentro del Rusia la situación no es
mejor a mí me llama mucho la atención
también que Estados Unidos pues trate de
empujar primero a Europa a que tenga
este apoyo cuando estamos viendo en
realidad que hay un conflicto entre
Rusia y occidente donde me parece que
Estados Unidos debe tener un papel si no
beligerante tratar de encontrar algún
tipo de solución y no extender este
conflicto que ahora mismo no se le ve
por donde va a aterrizar
y ahora paso a preguntarle a Hugo en la
ciudad de Madrid se muestra muy sólido
este bloque de los 27 en torno a la
ayuda de Ucrania muy diciente como lo
estábamos mencionando Esta visita de
estos representantes a las ciudades de
kiev cómo se toma allí al interior de la
Unión Europea estos hechos de esta
semana bueno pues realmente parece que
está todo mucho más cerca no Además con
palabras textuales vuestro futuro está
con nosotros eso fue lo que se dijo
bueno pues en esa en esa Cumbre que
verdaderamente ha sido histórica no una
cumbre celebrada en un país que está en
estos momentos en guerra eso no lo
podemos olvidar pero claro como decía yo
soy borrell pues hay que continuar con
la metodología que Hasta ahora ha sido
imperante que ahora se ha aplicado para
poder los países que entren a formar
parte de la Unión Europea más que nada
para legitimarla es decir si ahora
hacemos una excepción son
argumentaciones de borrel no y hacemos
una excepción con Ucrania evidentemente
se estaría de alguna forma pues
debilitando no esa metodología esa
legitimidad de la integración de en la
Unión Europea pero todo parece Insisto
que está más cerca no hay que tener en
cuenta y en relación con lo que decía
mi compañero es decir Ucrania realmente
antes de la guerra era un país en
decadencia no y ahora desde a raíz de la
guerra evidentemente pues ha ido tomando
relevancia en el panorama internacional
está evidentemente Pues en Boca de todos
los países ya ha ido ganando influencia
pero desde luego yo creo sinceramente y
eso es una ya una opinión personal que
hay que apostar por aquellos países que
quieran pues dejar atrás la corrupción
que quieran de alguna forma asentar la
democracia hacer valer la libertad y
desde aquí desde Europa lo que vemos
cosas la sensación que nos dan Bueno
pues a todos los europeos es que Ucrania
Ucrania está en esas vías no de asentar
Por tanto la democracia de convertirse
en un país bajo los parámetros y
estándares que rigen la Unión Europea No
veremos a ver qué ocurre desde luego la
guerra y concluyo parece que se está
enquistando Parece que va a ser una
guerra muy larga Eso que dicen los
expertos y que de forma pues esperemos
vaya debilitando a Putin aquí la
pregunta que queda y lo he estado
pensando a lo largo de estos días sobre
cuál es el futuro que necesita Ucrania O
tiene que tener Ucrania dado el contexto
en el que está Guillermo y con los
hechos de esta semana y Esta visita lo
representantes de la Unión Europea unos
se pregunta si de verdad lo que quiere
Ucrania es entrar a este círculo de
países de estos 27 países donde hay una
prioridad en torno al ciudadano con un
sistema de bienestar unos bajos
estándares unos altos estándares de
educación Pero unos bajos niveles de
corrupción donde hay una repartición de
recursos o si lo que busca Ucrania es la
Unión Europea como un mecanismo para
poder salirse del conflicto y de la
guerra y terminar este asunto porque en
el campo en lo militar si bien hay
avances pues la guerra como lo dice Hugo
se está enquistando y esto se está
alargando más de lo que todas las partes
y creo que el mundo entero estaban
esperando usted qué piensa es la fórmula
la Unión Europea la fórmula para Ucrania
Santiago Hugo bueno es que no le queda
de otra miren yo recuerdo de que baños
antes de que se diera el conflicto aquí
en Panamá ya yo conocí a varios
ciudadanos de Ucrania que se quejaban de
las pocas condiciones para el crecer
alguna persona algún joven el problema
de la corrupción el problema de que era
un país que se estaba quedando en la
cola de los países circundantes de los
países europeos en este caso ahora
qué necesita Ucrania necesita cambiar
esa esa dinámica de una vez por todas la
valentía selecto es aplaudible y es es
reconocible pero no basta con eso
Ucrania debe convertirse en el país que
está llamado a ser uno de los grandes
países de su área y si lo logra primero
que todo va a tener que conseguir que
todo ese efecto de jóvenes que sean se
han ido de Ucrania sobre todo gente que
se fue antes incluso de la invasión
vuelvan regresen y aporten a la economía
de Ucrania y ese va a ser el gran reto
que van a tener no solamente este
gobierno sino los futuros gobiernos de
reconstrucción de Ucrania Ahí es donde
debe entrar la Unión Europea con todo
apoyar hacer un plan marcha para para
Ucrania de manera de que se vuelva a
levantar y sea un dique de contención
precisamente para otros países que lo
vean de ejemplo si eso no se hace vamos
a vamos a seguir con este ciclo de
Ucrania siendo un país que se invade un
país con problemas internos de
corrupción compro rusos y antirrusos Y
eso pues va a generar inestabilidad en
las futuras décadas Hugo su opinión es
la Unión Europea la ruta para Ucrania O
podría llegar a ser que es otra
posibilidad que también se me ocurre en
este momento que Ucrania no le apuesta
ninguno de los dos lados y esto ya lo
habían comentado incluso al inicio de la
guerra que se convierta en un Estado
neutral hablaban de una finlandtización
de Ucrania y fuera un estado colchón
entre ese mundo Ruso y el mundo de la
Unión Europea puede ser esa otra opción
o la Unión Europea es la opción desde
luego y que se realistas no el que
Ucrania se integre en la Unión Europea
Pues eso podría conllevar una escalada
de las tensiones con Rusia en este caso
que claro ve una amenaza clara que la
otan por tanto una vez que si Ucrania
Integra en la Unión Europea que la otan
esté a las puertas de Rusia no Entonces
evidentemente esto podría aumentar la
tensión Pero sinceramente decir el modo
de vida en Ucrania yo que evidentemente
tengo Fuentes en Ucrania incluso o sea
tengo familia que está viviendo en
Ucrania y me dicen es que el modo de
vida de la gran inmensa mayoría de los
ucranianos es que es europeo es europeo
con lo cual yo sinceramente apostaría no
por un país que quiere por tanto
adaptarse a los parámetros de la Unión
Europea parámetros que se le va a exigir
porque una vez que forme parte de la
Unión Europea a pesar de que por cierto
está bastante debilitada a nivel
económico ha perdido mucho potencial
mucha influencia en el mundo la Unión
Europea pero a pesar de eso Hay unos
parámetros que se le exigen las normas
Fiscales tiene que haber unos índices
bajos de corrupción evidentemente tiene
que adaptarse por tanto a las normas que
le exige la Unión Europea con lo cual si
un país pues quiere Bueno pues como es
Ucrania insisto con una población
mayoritariamente de estilo de vida
europeo podemos decir pues si se quiere
integrar y hacer valer la democracia y
la libertad y el estado de bienestar que
le exige la Unión Europea en su país
pues Bienvenido sea no hay que decir
también que Rusia no tiene ningún
problema en cuanto a esta decisión por
parte de Ucrania el tema con Rusia es si
Ucrania se incorpora en la otan que es
una organización completamente distinta
ser Unión Europea no implica que sea
parte de la otan son dos organismos
distintos son dos procesos de
incorporación completamente distintos
tenemos por ejemplo a Turquía que es un
país de la otan pero no es un país de la
Unión Europea y sin embargo tiene una
relación cercana con Rusia Pese a que es
un país de la otan Entonces ahí es donde
uno empieza a mirar Pues cuál puede ser
el rumbo que podría tomar este país de
Cara a buscar una salida al conflicto o
Buscar una salida que no tal parece la
negociación en este momento no es la vía
no hay indicios de que las partes estén
dispuestas a negociar por lo menos en el
corto plazo pero por lo menos la gran
apuesta del presidente es por Bruselas
por ese proceso de reconstrucción que va
a hacer uso como lo estaba mencionando
yo jugo para hacer la ronda la inversa
de los recursos rusos congelados en
bancos europeos Como qué análisis puede
hacer usted de esto
Bueno pues antes de nada Claro yo me
refería a que también una de las
aspiraciones de Ucrania es entrar en la
otan como evidentemente se dijo son dos
procesos de integración completamente
diferentes pero está más cerca un país
de la Unión Europea en entrar en la otan
Demente Claro
en cualquier caso yo lo que creo Es que
sinceramente estamos ante un problema
económico a nivel global es todo la
crisis la crisis que está generando a
nivel mundial a raíz de esta de esta
guerra es radicalmente visible No de
hecho estamos en una auténtica paradoja
una paradoja no decir sin ir más lejos
España en el país en el que estoy pues
ha tenido por la crisis también
diplomática que tuvo con Argelia
incrementar la compra de Bueno pues de
en general tanto de petróleo como como
de gas de como de todo tipo de
importaciones a Rusia en el año pasado
ahora sí que es cierto que se está
rebajando nuevas importaciones pero
desde luego insisto estamos siendo
paradojas tan graves como que un país de
la Unión Europea como es España ha
incrementado en las importaciones por
parte vamos de Rusia no con lo cual esto
es una paradoja estamos viendo que bueno
todos necesitamos de todos estamos una
economía globalizada y es un problema
grave Claro claro Guillermo y por eso es
que entra está este anuncio de la Unión
Europea es importante a lo largo de esta
semana de usar estos fondos rusos para
la reconstrucción porque también los
países tal vez no puede haber un
compromiso muy grande a nivel
internacional para dar fondos para una
posible reconstrucción de Ucrania Porque
si bien ha habido una respuesta mundial
y se ha arropado a Ucrania con con el
tema de la invasión y se le da un apoyo
a nivel internacional pues ya a la hora
de donar dinero para la reconstrucción
pues tal vez no le queda muy fácil a
todos pero como vive usted esta donación
Perdón esta donación este uso de fondos
de la Unión Europea para la
reconstrucción fondos rusos Bueno es lo
correcto primero que es lo correcto
segundo es lo que esperaría los europeos
por qué tienes tienes varias situaciones
primero
pronto Tienes unas elecciones europeas
en un contexto donde los populismos
están pidiendo la salida y o alguna
revisión de la propia Unión Europea eso
ya le está costando popularidad a los a
muchos de los presidentes digamos que
moderados de Europa en este momento
además también tienes el otro tema de
que la otan hasta antes de esta invasión
era una organización en Franco declive
que hay que reconocerlo Vladimir Putin
hizo todo lo contrario lo que quería
logró darle vida a la otan en un momento
en el cual pues no se tenía muy claro
hacia dónde que Cuál era el rumbo que
iba a llevar entonces el ciudadano
europeo lo último que quiere es que
saquen de su bolsillo Para apoyar la
situación en Ucrania que lo paguen los
rusos es lo más seguro que si saca una
encuesta Lo más seguro es que los
europeos eso es lo que van a pedir y
algo que también provocó el presidente
Putin Guillermo lo añado a lo que usted
está comentando es que despertó entre
los ucranianos el profesionalismo y le
dio una identidad de nación a un país
que tenía una cultura muy arraigada pero
que le costaba cohesionarse como nación
como estado como sociedad eso lo logró
el conflicto Los vemos a ellos Unidos en
bloque para defender a su territorio
pues vamos a dejar hasta ahí el tema de
Ucrania para pasar a otro tema
importante la agenda y eso nos lleva
hasta América Latina porque en Perú El
Congreso no se pone de acuerdo a la hora
de aprobar o no esa propuesta hecha por
la presidenta Dina boluarte de adelantar
los comicios generales para este año
para el 2023 a lo largo de la semana
Estuvimos viendo las largas sesiones del
legislativo peruano debatiendo sobre
este tema y también varias veces fue
aplazada esta discusión por eso todavía
no hay un resultado hasta ahora sobre
qué rumbo va a tomar Perú también se
unió a esta propuesta inicial de las
elecciones de adelantar las elecciones
una consulta a los ciudadanos sobre si
desean o no realizar una asamblea
Constituyente para hacer algunos cambios
a una constitución entre tanto y en
ustedes viendo ahí en las
manifestaciones en las calles lo ven en
las imágenes de los ciudadanos que piden
la renuncia de la presidenta boluarte
Perú en este momento en punto muerto y
también sin encontrar un rumbo muy claro
hago la ronda la inversa comienzo
Entonces por Hugo en la ciudad de Madrid
preguntándole por las perspectivas aquí
esto ya no ya parece que se volvió fue
un juego de intereses de las bancadas de
los parlamentarios y se les olvida el
sentido puntual de su trabajo que es
definir y darle un punto de quiebre
hasta hasta crisis y buscarle un rumbo
al país bueno esto esto ocurre también
es cierto a nivel mundial es decir
cuando diputados llegan al congreso y
tocan el poder es muy difícil que lo que
lo suelten no dicho dicho rápido y claro
y es lo que estamos encontrando el
congreso hay que tener en cuenta que
tiene vamos es que hay muchos diputados
que están siendo investigados por
corrección hay mucha corrupción en Perú
con lo cual Es evidente que lo que está
en juego en Perú estos momentos es Ni
más ni menos que la democracia No yo soy
además de periodista y desde luego tal y
como nos decía el politólogo Robert para
que una democracia sea tal para que se
acerque esa ideal de poliarquía no hacen
falta libertad la asociación libertades
expresión libertad de Voto Libertad para
que los líderes políticos pues puedan
competir entre sin las elecciones y
diversidad de las fuentes de información
y es que en Perú pues no se está dando
es decir incluso hasta los propios
medios de comunicación la propia
asociación Nacional de prensa de Perú
está evidentemente pues denunciando un
acoso por parte
del poder político hacia los medios de
comunicación los ciudadanos nos están
saliendo informar correctamente y desde
luego la asamblea Constituyente que
piden tal y como se está poniendo encima
la mesa Pues es que no se puede llegar a
dar no es decir porque no lo contempla
la propia la propia constitución del
país No ese ese parámetro para
establecer una asamblea Constituyente ni
tan siquiera evaluarte pues puede llegar
a poner encima de la mesa esa asamblea
Constituyente no lo más que pueden
llegar a hacer y esto ha sido una
propuesta pues del partido Perú libre
pues es un proyecto de reforma
constitucional orientado a elaborar una
nueva constitución sería la única vía no
pero no no tal como se está enfocando en
estos momentos asamblea Constituyente
con lo cual yo creo que está en un
proceso también como decíamos antes
enquistado y desde luego lo que está en
juego es la democracia en Perú yo creo
que las elecciones tienen que
adelantarse que los peruanos pues puedan
elegir pero claro Hay un congreso
Insisto que está también Bueno pues
contenido por la corrupción y por las
ansias de preservar su poder claro
parece que se han llegado al final del
callejón se están estrellando con la
pared y además se han metido un tiro en
el pie porque tampoco pueden echar
reversa o tomar un giro adicional es un
callejón sin salida Guillermo su
impresión de lo que está pasando en Perú
este callejón sin salida punto muerto
Santiago de Hugo Déjenme adicionar un
par de puntos que creo que pueden ayudar
al debate primero desde la época del
presidente kusinski comenzaron a salir
capitales de Perú hacia Miami hacia
Panamá y hacia diferentes lugares
empresarios que les estaba yendo bien
recordemos que Perú es uno de los países
que más ha crecido en el producto
interno bruto en los últimos años y
incluso sigue creciendo a pesar de las
protestas que se están dando en estos
momentos otro elemento que hay que sumar
aquí es que los partidos políticos se
autodestruyeron y que la larga sombra
del fujimorismo sin fujimori acabó ayudó
a acabar con todo esto Entonces en este
momento Ninguno de los actores que están
en en el escenario político peruano
tiene una base sólida política que pueda
respaldar en las calles en la sociedad
alguna solución que sea lo más adecuada
posible la otra cosa que tiene es que la
Constitución Política de Perú
actualmente genera una doble arma una
donde en la mañana se levanta el
presidente y puede disolver el el
congreso Y esa misma mañana el congreso
se levanta y puede echar al presidente
entonces son dos poderes que están todos
los días amenazándose el uno al otro y
no importa quién va a ser sea el
presidente mientras esa situación claro
No se ve no se revise la sociedad
peruana no revise eso no va a haber
forma de que esto esto tenga un final
feliz porque va a venir otras elecciones
no va a tener la mayoría del Congreso Y
nuevamente va a estar en la misma
vorágine Entonces lo primero que hay que
hacer es revisar la Carta Magna porque
si no lo de Perú va a terminar
argentinizando Lamentablemente Guillermo
ahí entonces sí tendría mucho sentido
hacer una renovación de la de la
Constitución para definir muy bien
los rangos y los campos de acción tanto
legislativo como de el presidente Para
poder definir labores y que no estén
como usted dice acusándose pisándose uno
al otro tratando de disputar El Poder
para cerrar este tema de Perú le hago
esta misma pregunta cada semana los
periodistas que han estado a lo largo de
estos últimos días aquí en el programa
porque el tema de Perú es recurrente
cada semana porque hay novedades cuál
puede ser la salida la renuncia de
boluarte un cambio de gobierno la
Constituyente elecciones Hugo cuál
quiere usted Bueno pues yo creo que
antes lo decíamos no el propio Perú
libre dijo la solución desde luego que
hay que cambiar la Carta Magna Es
evidente no más que nada para que haya
una verdadera separación de poderes y
unas funciones claras no de cada de cada
poder y es un proyecto de reforma
constitucional orientado a elaborar una
nueva constitución Es decir desde luego
que la Carta Magna como decíamos yo creo
que hay que modificarla pero es que hay
que encontrar el mecanismo adecuado que
no vaya en contra de la ley para
modificarla tiene todo todo cambio todo
proceso tiene que ir de la ley hacia la
ley no no se puede saltar la ley como
propone evidentemente una una parte
política en Perú no se puede llevar a
cabo esa asamblea Constituyente tal y
como se pide no los parámetros que se
pide y desde luego yo creo que cada día
se está incrementando más el descontento
social en Perú con lo cual el adelanto
de elecciones como pide el partido
fujimori pues parece que puede ser lo
más lo más a corto plazo lo más racional
no Claro Guillermo su opinión
tiene que haber un consenso político que
una vez ganado las elecciones cualquiera
de los que gane ese consenso se cumpla y
tiene que partir por revisar la ley
revisar la Carta Magna y revisarlo es
que en este momento parece haber una
guerra civil dentro de la izquierda
peruana pero también están bueno el
presidente del Congreso general en
retiro y el y el alcalde de Lima es un
líder más cercano a una derecha digamos
muy conservadora claro Entonces cuando
tú ves este escenario es muy complicado
si no hay un consenso político en Perú
donde todas las partes se pongan de
acuerdo antes de ir a las elecciones yo
veo poco probable que esto se resuelva
en el en el corto tiempo pasamos al
tercer tema del programa esta semana
también se cumplieron tres años del
inicio del proceso del brexit y el
balance que hacen los británicos sobre
todo en materia económica pues son
balances podemos decirlo agridulce la
deseada de Independencia la libertad Y
esa proyección del Reino Unido a nivel
internacional Pues no ha tenido lugar
todavía la pandemia del Coby 19 también
la guerra en Ucrania ha generado muchas
complicaciones en ese anhelo de los
británicos y hay que sumarle la crisis
económica que está viviendo el país ese
descontento las protestas que vimos a lo
largo de esta semana en diferentes
regiones en los cuatro países que
conforman el Reino Unido la crisis
política ha sido evidente también allí
en el Reino Unido con cambios de
gobierno y pues tampoco ayuda a la moral
de la sociedad británica la muerte de la
reina Isabel segunda en los últimos
meses entonces pues ahora mientras él
Reino Unido pues camina solo en el
escenario internacional la Unión Europea
Tal parece que ya ha superado el proceso
del brexit ha cerrado el capítulo Y pues
ahora ellos miran al Reino Unido como
Bueno estamos solos pero no estamos mal
acompañados qué balance se puede hacer
del Reino Unido después de estos tres
años de brexit Guillermo
no le está yendo bien definitivamente
pues parecía que había esperanzas con él
pero no le va bien Y lamentablemente
cuando uno ve las encuestas las últimas
encuestas de este fin de semana
el partido conservador tampoco levanta
cabeza aquí Esto va a terminar en unas
elecciones anticipadas en el Reino Unido
lo que no sé si va a ser el próximo año
a final de este pero ya comienzan a
darse fisuras dentro de la sociedad este
esta semana pasada la huelga que se dio
importante en el Reino Unido y vemos del
otro lado en el sector privado deportivo
fichajes multimillonarios Entonces el el
británico de a pie se debe se debe estar
preguntando Pero bueno Cómo puede haber
tantos mundos tan separados a todo esto
hay que sumarle la desavenencias en
Escocia por la idea de si se siguen o no
dentro de la Gran Bretaña y todo lo que
ha conllevado como bien lo decía
Santiago la muerte de la reina Isabel
segunda que Australia hay un debate si
sigue si se pone a Carlos tercero en la
moneda o sea todo se ha complicado en el
Reino Unido y necesita un liderazgo
fuerte un verdadero mandato en este
momento que lamentablemente Ricky es por
con su
buen rollito como dice como dicen en
España pues no es suficiente sí necesita
un rumbo esto es otro país que también
necesita un Norte Tal parece que es como
la tendencia a nivel internacional Hugo
su su impresión sobre este sobre estos
tres años del brexit Bueno pues desde
luego ha afectado claramente a cuatro
puntos sobre todo a nivel económico no
el primero ha sido el comercio es decir
realmente ha decrecido ha decrecido el
comercio no de Reino Unido con el resto
de países se han cerrado 71 nuevos
acuerdos comerciales y de todo tipo con
otros países pero eran ya acuerdos Que
prácticamente estaban preestablecidos
cuando Reino Unido pues formaba parte de
la europea con lo cual realmente
acuerdos nuevos es decir se está viendo
un déficit a la hora de conseguir
insisto fuerzas comerciales y la hora
atención también de captar inversión y
luego además el claro cuando Ya dejamos
cuando deja de formar parte de una Unión
además europea también sobre todo
monetaria No pues claro los trabajadores
que eso es un punto también muy
importante que ha afectado la economía
de de Reino Unido es que no tiene libre
circulación con lo cual ahora tienen que
pasar una serie de puntos como si los
trabajadores se quieran ir a Estados
Unidos vaya redundancia a trabajar como
si fueran inmigrantes es decir salir de
una Unión monetaria como lo es la Unión
Europea pues desde luego conlleva ese
tipo de riesgos y son estos cuatro
puntos comercio
inversión el tema del trabajo y luego la
economía en general está viendo se está
viendo debilitada Hugo añado a esa parte
de los acuerdos comerciales el gran
acuerdo al que le estaba apostando el
Reino Unido que era el acuerdo comercial
con Estados Unidos que todavía no ha
tenido lugar y era la gran Apuesta para
reemplazar en buena parte el mercado de
la Unión Europea reemplazarlo por el
mercado de los Estados Unidos y hacer un
poco de contrapeso y balance y
garantizar las exportaciones británicas
eso no ha tenido lugar y eso sin duda ha
pasado factura a nivel económico vamos
ahora al último bloque del programa para
ir cerrando y tenemos que hablar de el
Papa Francisco que estuvo esta semana
por África visitó la República
democrática del Congo y también Sudán
del sur que son países inmersos en
conflictos internos armados con muchas
dificultades a nivel social el pontífice
habló sobre la situación en la República
democrática del Congo ante una multitud
en el principal estadio de quinchasa la
capital con golesa posteriormente partió
hacia Yuba la capital de Sudán del sur
que es uno de los países más jóvenes del
mundo Pero también es uno de los más
pobres económicamente hablando qué tan
significativa es la visita del Papa
católico al continente
americano sobre todo a estos dos países
en particular países en cierta forma
abandonados por la comunidad
internacional inmersos en conflictos y
que llegue el papa con estos mensajes
religiosos esto en la actualidad qué
tanto peso tiene Hugo Bueno hay que hay
que ver el peso sobre todo de África no
África parece que es el futuro del
catolicismo sí que es cierto que a nivel
total si hablamos de África en su
conjunto Pues el catolicismo todavía
vamos no es pujante no pero sí que por
ejemplo si hablamos del Congo de la
República democrática del Congo es que
el 90% de la población es cristiana y le
hemos visto con esa recepción de más de
un millón de personas al papa no se
entiende que África es el futuro del
catolicismo y por tanto evidentemente El
Vaticano el propio papa pues está tan
dispuesto Bueno pues eso a a ir a África
y por tanto a impulsar el catolicismo en
ese país que insisto lo ven como el
propio futuro luego es muy relevante en
Sudán del sur no las palabras que dijo
el que dijo el papá en relación a las
mujeres que cuando se va en contra de
las mujeres que cuando se agrede a las
mujeres también se agrede a Dios no son
palabras yo creo que claves suán del sur
un país que bueno que las mujeres Pues
por desgracia no pueden ir
solas a muchas a muchos lugares por
miedo a que las violen por miedo a que
las exploten sexualmente por miedo Bueno
pues a sufrir no Esa esa violencia con
lo cual yo creo que es muy interesante
tanto a nivel de catolicismo como
también a nivel de luchar por esas
libertades por esos derechos que en
países como por ejemplo Sudán del sur
hacen falta a las mujeres y bueno y a
tantas personas para respetar sus
derechos fundamentales pues por lo menos
es un líder de importancia y relevancia
a nivel internacional que está llegando
a estos territorios a donde no han
llegado otros que deberían de estar
haciendo presencia allí Guillermo
adelante sus impresiones
en un momento en que el catolicismo está
en Franco retroceso en sus grandes
bastiones que son América Latina y por
supuesto Europa como siempre pero no
solamente en la cantidad de creyentes
son las que están están retrocediendo
sino también el estilo de vida Cristiano
está retrocediendo y el papa pues
apuesta a buscar caladeros en donde
muchos como bien decías muchos no han
entrado
en este momento África no solamente es
un país importante en cuanto a la
magnitud en la que se puede crecer hacer
crecer el catolicismo sino también por
su por su demografía por el la explosión
demográfica que están teniendo en el
centro de África y lo mismo ha estado
apostando a Asia y además también
tenemos que señalar que el papa no la
está teniendo en su no está en su mejor
momento en en la situación interna del
Vaticano y esto también le da un aire a
él dentro de lo que a él más le gusta
como que es pues predicar en lugares
donde la gente lo pide y lo necesita es
el viaje número 40 del pontífice a nivel
internacional y llegó a África a pesar
de estas complicaciones de salud venía
con problemas en la rodilla por eso lo
vimos en silla de ruedas haciendo
algunos de los desplazamientos par de
minutos para el cierre del programa
Quiero preguntarle a los dos a Qué temas
estarán poniendo ustedes el ojo la lupa
para la próxima semana que temas van a
estar tratando en sus redacciones a lo
largo de los próximos cinco días
comienzo entonces con Guillermo para
hacer la ronda la inversa Guillermo
adelante Bueno yo hay que darle
seguimiento lo que está pasando en
Brasil la declaración del presidente
Lula acusando a bolsonaron van a generar
un conflicto político importante en ese
país sobre todo porque la mayor parte
del control de las cámaras está
precisamente del lado de bolsonaro que
se encuentra todavía en Estados Unidos
tema que también vamos a tener en el
debate de France 24 la próxima semana
Hugo sus temas para la próxima semana
pues desde luego Ucrania sigue siendo un
tema importante en cada semana pero
luego también hay que focalizar un
problema importante que estamos teniendo
en España y es el tema de la ley del
solo sí de sí que es una nueva ley
impulsada por el Ministerio de igualdad
en este caso que por fallos técnicos en
la ley como ya reconoce Incluso el
propio gobierno de España desde el
gobierno Pedro Sánchez está dejando la
calle a violadores y agresores sexuales
y están rebajando sus condenas también
es decir beneficiando aquellos que han
cometido violencia ajeno hacia las
mujeres es un problema importantísimo
que está en debate aquí en España que
siguen debate y que marcará yo creo que
la agenda los próximos días sí ha sido
un tema polémico para la sociedad
española Hugo Guillermo les agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros aquí
en una semana en el mundo haber
compartido sus impresiones sus opiniones
sobre los temas destacados de la semana
ustedes pueden seguir dejando los
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]